what's up dudes this is ideas of Ice and
Fire what are the others the White
Walkers I know we've seen them a couple
times in the books about what type of
creature are they and where did they
come from well I think I might actually
have the answer now for you guys to
understand what I'm talking about you're
going to have to look at this quote from
george RR martin the others are not dead
they are strange beautiful think oh the
city made of ice something like that a
different sort of life in a human
elegant dangerous all right so the TV
show didn't really get the whole elegant
and beautiful thing right but hold on
what's a she
George describes the others as she made
of ice well she is short for I she which
are mythical race of beings from pseudo
Irish history the STR often compared to
fairies or elves and they're also called
the spirits of nature an additional
either thought to be the fierce
guardians of their bones which are often
special trees okay now these guys are
starting to sound more and more familiar
but Before we jump to any conclusions
let's look at the rest of the story
now the icd had previously ward with
another race called the Malaysians who
came to Ireland across the sea from
Iberia
does she even conjure up a great
windstorm using some type of magic to
prevent the Malaysians from entering the
land so eventually the Malaysians and
the Siddi make a pact and they decide to
split Ireland the Malaysians take the
world above and the she take the world
below also called the Otherworld ok now
this is starting to sound really
familiar let's compare this to a Song of
Ice and Fire and the books the children
of the forest are described as a
nonhuman mysterious race that inhabits
Westeros before the arrival of the first
men and also before the arrival of the
Andals much like the nonhumans she
inhabited Ireland before the Malizia
came the children of the forest war with
the first men who came from ystos across
the Narrow Sea at one point they used
magic against the first men attempting
to split Westeros in half and even
breaking the arm of Dorne again much
like the she ward with the Malaysians
who come across the sea from Iberia and
the she also used magic to conjure a
windstorm to prevent the mouse from
entering the land from a sea after a
bunch of war the children in the first
men end up making a deal and the
children get the Deepwood in the first
men get everything else very similar to
the way this she and the Malaysians
agreed to divide Ireland so it seems
like george RR martin has taken these
elements from irish mythology and put
them into a song of ice and fire the ice
she are clearly the children of the
forest and the Malaysians are clearly
the first men and partially the Andals
so if the Shi are the children of the
forest and george RR martin describes
the others as looking like she but made
of ice then is he implying that the
others are simply another type of
children of the forest or at least a
branch of their people that perhaps
discovered a different type of magic the
children of the forest don't all think
with the same mind so they can't all be
alike they've spent thousands of year is
confined to the deep woods Westeros is
rightfully theirs their numbers have
severely dwindled but there's nothing
they can do about it and it's because
they're not strong they have magic but
the first men are stronger bigger
they've got better weapons they've got
more consistent fighting tactics so is
it conceivable that some of them wit off
and through means which are still very
cloaked in mystery
became the others now we don't know
exactly what lies within the land of
always winter but I'm going to give a
little bit of speculation perhaps these
children journey to the land of always
winter and discovered some entity
perhaps they made a deal with this
entity now I'm not exactly sure what
they would have to offer this entity but
perhaps this entity offered them the
ability to defeat mankind not only could
this entity give them power to become
stronger physically and give them the
ability to make superior armor and
superior weapons to the humans it would
also no longer matter if there are only
a few of them left to oppose humanity as
they can use the bodies of humans that
they kill as their thralls but with the
power that these children who become the
others are granted there is a price and
the price is wherever they go cold and
darkness follow so the children of the
forest would essentially be betraying
everything that makes them limb a forest
can't grow in darkness but you also have
to make the assumption that there are
children of the forest that didn't
become the others since children appear
in advance with dragons and these
children I don't think would be okay
with the forest been frozen and constant
darkness because they're all about
nature so when the last hero asked for
help to stop the others why would they
say no but alas there really is no
evidence for some power granting deity
in the land of always winter but is that
in A Song of Ice and Fire there's a
being described by the prophets of her
lore as a god of darkness cold and death
he is the opposite to renew himself and
known only as the great other his true
name is never spoken and Melisandre
certainly seems to believe that he is
the one responsible for the white
walkers beyond the wall the enemy grows
stronger and should he when the dawn
will never come again
death is his domain and the dead his
soldiers and once at the wall when
gazing into the fire Milla Saunders sees
a pale face almost like a corpse and a
thousand red eyes and a boy was a wolf's
head sitting right beside him and she
thinks to herself these must be the
champions of the great other but wait
that describes brand and Bloodraven who
are working with the children of the
forest and they're the good guys right
hmm now that I do think about it they
were led to the children of the forest
in blood Ravens cave by a reanimated
corpse who seemed to be brought back by
a magic similar to that used by the
others okay there is indeed something
quite strange going on in that cave with
the children of the forest and blood
Raven just think about it for a second
there's this guy seemingly inexplicably
in this cave surrounded by children of
the forest and he's plugged into this
tree and he's got the vines and the
thorns growing through his body and he's
unnaturally old and scary-looking and
he's just down there in the dark
watching everything I think the simple
fact of the matter is we don't have
enough pieces of the puzzle could the
others have finally convinced the
remaining children of the forest to join
their cause against the humans perhaps
possibly I don't know in conclusion I
believe that the story of the children
of the forest versus the first men is
essentially the story of the she and the
malaysians
and the George RR Martin's quote implies
what I believe it implies then that
means that the others could be descended
from the children of the forest thank
you guys for watching make sure you like
this video and subscribe for more ideas
of Ice and Fire
you